The Waimakariri District Council meeting for
June started with the acknowledgement of two
Queens Birthday honours, awarded to residents
of our District.
Mary Mackintosh received the Queens Service
Medal for her services to the community, including
over 30 years of volunteer work for the Anglican
Parish of Kaiapoi, local orienteering groups
and various school boards in the Kaiapoi area.
Gabrielle Huria was appointed a Member of
the New Zealand Order of Merit for her work
in Pacific and Maori mental health, communications
work with Ngai Tahu and volunteer work in
running film and communications courses for
young Maori.
Post-earthquake, she has been instrumental
in the development of infrastructure and land
zone reform at Tuahiwi, and is currently acting
chair of the Marae.
Council then considered a small parcel of
land in the Rangiora Town Centre which was
acquired for the Red Lion corner road realignment.
With roading work complete, this land is no
longer needed, however due to its size and
location, it is unsuitable for commercial
development.
Council approved the land being put into reserve,
which suits the current landscaping and aligns
with the wishes of the Rangiora-Ashley Community
Board.
Councillors also approved for the Business
Zones 1 & 2 Public Spaces Policy to be made
available for public consultation.
This policy focuses on making Council’s
public spaces safe and accessible for people
to enjoy.
It establishes regulations for things such
as outdoor dining areas, smoking outdoors,
and links Bylaws and District Plan regulation
for store signage, busking, collecting for
charity and lighting.
The policy is expected to be open for public
feedback later this month.
The council also made progress on planning
for an extended kerbside collection service,
which is expected to be introduced once the
Long Term Plan is adopted on June 19.
Council has the option of owning the new bins,
or the successful kerbside collection contractor
owning the bins.
Due to little difference in overall cost and
the administrative and maintenance work required
in owning the bins ourselves, the Council
opted for the latter option.
This will be similar to the current arrangement
in place for our yellow recycling bins.
The Council would consider alternative tender bids which include the Council owning the bins.
The next Council Meeting will be on Tuesday
19 June, where the Long Term Plan will be
formally adopted.